si bien irá aquí el resto del mundo
conmemora el asesinato del general de
las fuerzas qods iraquíes que hacen
suleimán y el 3 de enero en irán se
conmemora hoy porque así lo recuerda el
calendario persa y así también lo
recuerdan la mayoría de los periódicos
locales que vienen con grandes fotos del
general qasem soleimani recordando lo
que han dicho la mayoría de las
autoridades de la república islámica y
es que irán vengar a la muerte de este
general y aseguran que tiene 48 personas
en las listas lideradas por el
presidente de los eeuu hasta hoy
donald trump y es que este aniversario
también llega en un momento de gran
tensión con eeuu aquí nadie descarta un
posible enfrentamiento en estas últimas
tres semanas antes de que trump se
retire de la casa blanca' la atención es
muy grande especialmente en irak donde
los generales iraníes han recordado a
sus aliados locales especialmente a
estas milicias iraní pro iraníes que
conforman el frente de movilización
popular de que por favor no realicen
ninguna acción que pueda causar la real
de eeuu recordemos que casi en su lema
'ni no solamente fue asesinado en bagdad
sino que con él también estaba quien era
el segundo de estas milicias aboal
mojantes que era uno de los grandes
aliados de irán en bagdad así que todo
el mundo
aquí en este país y en esta región del
mundo está pendiente de lo que pueda
suceder en estas últimas horas en un día
en que irán también conmemora hoy ahora
la muerte de quien fuera al ayatolá más
radical el que sigue la mayoría de estas
milicias mesbah yazdi que murió ayer en
teherán por complicaciones de salud